can you still be a high value woman if
you've been promiscuous in your past
this is a sad question I think there are
so many people in the red pill community
that are saying oh if you're not a
virgin then you're worthless as a woman
which is ridiculous you guys probably
know I'm not a fan of Promise cutie I
think it's damaging to men and women but
I think it's particularly damaging to
women I know some women will be
promiscuous when they're younger and
then grow up and regret it and I would
say forgive yourself like you would
forgive a friend there's no point in
carrying that around with you and it's
not tied to your worth at all if you're
a human and you make mistakes then you
identify the mistake and you try and fix
it and you try to become the person that
you admire and that's all anybody can do
and if there are people in your life
saying something makes you worthless get
rid of those people stop listening to
the red pill stuff because it's not tied
to your worth just try to be better
every day and try not to repeat things
that make you feel better that hurt you